добочки під стінами верховної ради вибір
гранати один за риби та десяткою
поранених з та рідних провал ховати
це журналісти ціліше за голосування за
поправкою до української конституції
які на думку маніфестантів може
локалізуватися проросійських
сепаратистів на донбасі та одразу
українці раки виступають проти мінус на
ногу закону на вище радикали
ми розуміємо що полиці україна на вигляд але
вийти контроль за occupy ванною на
території ми
бутіки повного дружина
чебуреки фінанси біржами може бути
апарату нею тим хто сьогодні я науку
паван їх територіях батька та російські
скроні російські найманти та сепаратиста
пенсіонер зелій відкриті до наряду та на
вид з члена поправках на поливають заходи
партнери України неприємний козмін
вожатих ідеї розміном українського
суверенітету на за мною раніше кремля
привели до поправок з фіджі в нього
кращого не демонструється пари жуку
структурно міхура до його сема ж є
продемонструвати і нашим партнерам
членом проукраїнської коаліції світловий
якоб фактично
з ну я ще україна в ікони взяти та носи
базове в'язання ще україна їде по
візуальним партнером на заходиш по
діваються що ви куна не кривим свої
частими зубів казань ви відкрили шлях для
мирного врегулювання а порошенка
зніяковілий присохла ти сюди думка
партнер fedec та взяла жити кулі точно
це фінансово Петро img околиці ліс лише
в це з мінським обком вибух що і мінську
води будуть виконані на сході України
західного світу лише в результаті cool і донецьк
та луганськ
досвід вас апаратних регіонів і
відкривають особливий статус у рамках України
Оце може стати і сили США в рамках
децентралізації країни ці ключової
момент для ви вирішення всі ігри
змушувати себе кінцях visit and for all
а на вигляд не хлопчики експерти впізнають
успіх усьому сценарію на ґрунтований
руси чоловіка і дали ви гачкуватий донбас
для пискуна захи не країни
оскільки час вся проблема в тому ще у
криммінс co2 тваринного плану
я там у на україну так ти знати тому
човен і на з локшини і long вивчу
музичному контексті ще nadia
якуз протиснутися мінськ-2 хоча очевидно
chemnitz 2 функції голосування продам у
штурвала у порошенка є петренко
парламент у алли для друга вчить, а не
забути про конституцію набіль шістьма 2
витрати на отримавши від і бішкеку ст їх то
Петро та майстер не поправка цьому боротьба
за нову українську конституцію покращує
підкоряється